la vente des vins des hospices de beaune
cet événement caritatif annuel attire
chaque année des milliers de visiteurs
tout le week end mais cette année la
158e édition risque d'être perturbé le
semi marathon et une partie du programme
ont lieu le samedi en même temps que le
mouvement national de blocage routier
contre la hausse des prix de l'essence
de quoi peut-être faire hésiter certains
visiteurs mais les membres du mouvement
l'assurent il ne compte pas mettre en
péril cet événement nova part à
l'intérieur du centre-ville éviter de
déranger les commerçants on sait que
c'est aussi une vente caritative pour
l'hôpital de beaune le but est vraiment
de ces revoir et de dire bah voilà stop
nous aussi on en a marre qu'on peut plus
vite dans ces conditions là on voit trop
de misère autour de nous à beaune trois
points de blocages sont prévus sur les
trois ronds points principaux réunis ce
soir en collectif les organisateurs
comme les commerçants de la ville ont
prévu des plans b pour contourner
d'éventuels obstacles
nous on veut une ville vivante et on
veut pas une ville morte comme on ne le
propose
en face on va proposer des animations
comme on a l'habitude de le faire que ce
soit le semi marathon
que ce soit les commerçants que ce soit
bien sûr le comité des fêtes que je
représente
c'est une ville qui est en fait et qui
ne peut pas subir une prise en otage
la préfecture a prévu de recevoir demain
à 10 heures les organisateurs du
mouvement de blocage pour leur signifier
l'accord ou non de cette manifestation
en cas de refus le mouvement a déjà
prévenu ne pas pouvoir garantir qu'il
soit scrupuleusement respectée